this world wasn't always so small and
petty thousands of years ago while the
rest of men prayed to gods the Valyrians
became them through magic or sheer will
they mastered the greatest creatures in
history a horse grunts man dominion over
the land a ship over the sea but dragons
gave us the sky and everything and
everyone beneath it at its height
my ancestors ruled the known world
whatever parts we didn't Wentworth known
our capital of Valyria shamed the
Magnificent cities of the East for
hammers and chisels were no match for
Dragon Fire and sorcery it was a city
and an empire built to last until the
end of time it didn't
400 years ago the doom fell on Valyria
mountains cracked open like eggs lakes
and rivers boiled fountains of fire ash
and smoke spewed from the ground so high
and so hot that even dragons burned in a
flight the land splintered and the angry
sea rushed in in hours the greatest city
in history became history but my
ancestors didn't burn nor drown with the
rest of their race 12 years before the
doom despite the sneers of his rivals
aina Targaryen abandoned the capital
with his family legends claim that his
daughter foresaw the destruction of the
city in a dream more likely a nar met
with some mishap at court and chose
exile over execution he and House
Targaryen slicked away to a dreary
remote godforsaken Island
forsaken no longer with arts now lost to
the world we transformed a tiny outpost
into Dragonstone a fortress fit for the
last dragon Lords then a nars
descendants settled into it like a tomb
for their lost homeland
until ago when he looked east he saw the
past old tired dead
but when he lived West he saw the future
gold in the world gold in the fields and
no dragons in the sky but is he and his
sisters Rhaenys and Visenya flew over
the great continent ostensibly visitors
to a strange land but when Aegon
returned he ordered construction of a
massive table carved in the shape of
Westeros with all the notable rivers and
mountains that they had seen a personal
map of the Seven Kingdoms then ruled by
seven squabbling families house-door
ndon held the Stormlands from their
seated storm's end due south of
Dragonstone house horror of the Iron
Islands had also conquered and enslaved
the Riverlands and ruled them from
Harrenhal a monstrous castle rising on
the shore of the Gods I how stark held
the frozen wasteland of the North the
oldest largest and emptiest of the
kingdom as lannister held the
westerland's the wealthiest kingdom
thanks to their gold mines house
gardener held the reach of the second
wealthiest Kingdom thanks to their crops
as Aaron held the Vale or rather the
Vale held them the mountains were
impassable except through the bloody
gate which had never been taken
house martell alt the deserts are doomed
from the plate because no one else
wanted them together the seven kingdoms
made Westeros a realm that wasn't yet a
realm ruled by great families who didn't
know what greatness was Aegon would
teach them
hey everybody big surprise HBO dropped
this big history bonus feature in
advance of season 8 like they're getting
ready to drop the DVDs later this year
sometimes they produce animated content
for stuff that the TV show isn't gonna
deal with which I'm also doing a
giveaway for so all you have to do to
enter that is just be a subscriber and
leave a game of Thrones comment on this
video I'll announce a new winner at the
end of this but the funny thing about
this is that it's you know for the
history of Valyria in the early history
of the Targaryen family but it's also
narrated by Harry Lloyd the series so
Daenerys his brother who's a very
pompous person talks about ancient
Valyria in a very pompous way it
shouldn't be too much of a surprise that
he thinks very highly of the people that
he descends from but I like the way that
he talks about Aegon being a pragmatist
but just because he only conquered the
Seven Kingdoms after leaving Dragonstone
doesn't mean that they didn't go back to
the east a couple times during his
lifetime the other important thing about
this is the idea that we haven't had a
flashback to ancient Valyria and I think
that's largely in favor of leaving that
for one of the prequel series to deal
with so keep that in the back of your
mind one of the five prequels that
they're developing most of them are
centered around big historical events
the doom of Valyria or even the rise of
Illyria which i think is a better option
is just one of those possibilities so I
believe that the version of this that
they'll release with the DVD is actually
gonna be longer because they sort of
brush over a lot of early Valyrian
history because as the Valerians learned
to tame dragons they conquered the
ghiscari empire in order to rule that
area of the kingdom and then obviously
there are a lot of other places in the
east that we haven't been yet GT is this
really big expansive area that's
actually much older than the Valyrian
freehold and was much richer at its
height which is why it's so funny to
listen to Viserys talk about how amazing
the Valyrians were because there are
even older cultures that felt ruined
before them but the cool thing about the
freehold that's different from Westeros
is that they actually ruled by committee
that was sort of like a ruling council
you would elect archons but each family
had a financial interest in the freehold
and that was sort of their participation
in the government like the Targaryen for
instance were a relatively minor house
they weren't that big of a deal the
reason why they're so big is because
they had the foresight thanks to
dan is the dreamer who had the vision of
the doom to leave before everything
ended up in flames they kind of brush
over that and this but they do give you
the idea that everybody thought that it
was going to be this wonderful Kingdom
that would live on forever and they're
all having this party here on top of
this spire and then it all just blows up
so the thing that Viserys conveniently
leaves out of this is that they used a
lot of slave labor to build their empire
in - so yes the Dragons gave them great
power but a lot of their actual monetary
wealth came from all the precious
minerals in and around the 14 flames but
if you've ever heard of any of the
geological theories of why the doomed
happened the ideas is that they might
have been on a fault line in hundreds of
years of over mining just destabilized
the area in and around the volcanoes
causing them to erupt again so the idea
was is that it wasn't all of them
erupting at once it was one going off
and then that sending off a chain
reaction that caused the other fourteen
flames to erupt and that's how when they
say that everything went up in smoke and
fire in hours that's why it happened so
quickly it was like an early event that
set off a chain reaction so it only
seemed like it was happening very
quickly but because we know that magic
exists in the world the children of the
forest even smashed the arm of Dorne
with the hammer of waters there's also a
lot of theories that there was some
magical element that caused the fourteen
flames to erupt so there haven't been
any answers about that George R Martin
hasn't painted any light on that only
the idea that is this changing of the
seasons the shifting of the balance of
power so you have R allure the red God
creatures born of fire the Dragons then
you have the night King creatures born
of ice the whites but while I do think
we'll continue to get Robert's rebellion
flashbacks during season eight maybe a
couple brief ones because there's only
six episodes just to sort of spell out
the rest of Rhaegar and Lyanna story is
that they leave a lot of the Valyrian
history for potential prequel series
because it's just too rich and too
interesting to not explore if you have
the opportunity so just remember that
there are five different stories they're
developing right now the Blackfyre
rebellion is another pick that George R
Martin has not shot down there's a
couple ideas that he said that they're
definitely not doing Robert's rebellion
is one of them entails of Dunkin egg is
the other those are the only two that he
shot down so any other big historical
event is toad
up for grabs and it doesn't necessarily
have to be in Westeros they did say some
of the ideas were in the East which i
think is a subtle way of confirming that
one of the ideas is a Valyrian prequel
but let me know in the comments what do
you guys think about them producing this
animated content what would you think
about an adult animated Game of Thrones
series as long as it was adult and in
keeping with the tone of Game of Thrones
like you probably don't want the Disney
Channel animated version of Game of
Thrones that would just make people
angry so because I wasn't expecting them
to drop this my next game of Thrones
video will be a character video but
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner miss Kerr please private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact details there for
the copies of the DVD now I'll name a
new winner when I post new Game of
Thrones you can click here for brand new
season 8 and you can click here for all
my other Game of Thrones videos thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight